Then a worker rolls
non-skid paint on the
inside so it won't
become slick when wet.
They bring in
incandescent heat lamps
and the paint dries
quickly in the warm glow.
After just 30 minutes,
the paint is dry.
Then it's time to see if
it'll float.
They transfer the
aluminum canoe to a tank
of water. They clamp a
bar across the canoe to
apply 450kg of pressure,
more than the weight of
two people. They check
for leaks, especially
around the rivets.
There are none.
Crossbars and bench
seating complete the
fabrication. There's one
last bit of business, and
that's the company
insignia. This aluminum
canoe is now ready for
recreation.
Ten hours in the making.
The fun has only just
begun.